he escuchado infinitas maneras para
definir las actuales generaciones de
jóvenes generación
iceta alza con millenials sentencias yo
ya me pierdo así que me plantee como
objetivo encontrar un concepto que
pudiera definirnos con más exactitud y
buscando y buscando encontré uno que
para mí no representa a la perfección
generación bumerán
un bumerán como todos sabéis si no
impacta en su objetivo regresa a su
punto de origen y sabéis por qué me di
cuenta de que somos la generación número
porque somos esos jóvenes que sí que
parecía que después de graduarnos
conseguiríamos trabajo que conseguimos
prácticas y por fin parece que salimos
del nido que soñamos con independizan o
por fin pero de repente
volvemos a casa de nuestros padres
porque no tenemos dinero y tampoco
trabajo
yo tengo casi 24 años me he graduado en
la universidad y estoy terminando un
máster he realizado cursos de mi
especialidad en universidades
extranjeras he asistido a escuelas de
idiomas he realizado prácticas en cinco
sitios distintos la mayoría de ellas sin
remunerar o cuya remuneración ha sido
tan baja que ni siquiera ha llegado a un
euro la hora es un hecho que todos
conocemos pero que en realidad no sólo
afecta nuestro colectivo
yo también soy la hija de unos padres
preocupados porque en el futuro tengo
una estabilidad laboral y económica yo
soy la nieta de unos abuelos que
lucharon porque el futuro de hoy fuera
mejor que el suyo yo soy en definitiva
la representación de un problema que se
enfrenta a los jóvenes pero un problema
que cualquier familia se enfrenta en
realidad por eso he querido averiguar
hasta qué punto este problema no sólo es
una cuestión personal sino que también
es estructural y lo que me encontré fue
esto
solo un 19 de los jóvenes consiguen
emanciparse antes de los 30 como es
posible que un 80 por ciento de los
jóvenes no consigamos independizarnos
antes de los 30 y por si no fuera poco
este problema ha crecido aún más
consecuencia de la pandemia
según la organización internacional del
trabajo uno de cada seis jóvenes ha
perdido su empleo por la crisis del cobi
vivimos en una sociedad democrática en
una sociedad libre pero vivimos en una
sociedad que realmente nos permita ser
independientes porque la libertad
también es autonomía pero en esta
situación de precariedad nuestra vida no
la ordenamos nosotros es más este verano
incluso me llamó un amigo y me dijo rosa
sabéis que estoy muy contento porque me
han elegido en el trabajo aunque bueno
no me pagan y sé que voy a tener que
trabajar sin descanso y yo le respondí
bueno pero tendrás un horario más o
menos fijado en el contrato y él me
contestó sí pero bueno ya sabes cómo van
estas cosas es que estamos en la edad de
que nos explote
estamos en la edad de que nos exploten
estáis cuenta de todo lo que esconde
esta frase vivimos en un sistema que nos
ha convertido a los jóvenes y ciudadanos
sumisos sin ser conscientes de ello y a
diferencia de lo que sucedía en otras
épocas no hay un enemigo concreto y
visible sino que hay enemigos en
apariencia el motor que nos impulsa
enemigo te acompaña otra vez
convirtiendo tú en tu propio enemigo
y es tan frecuente el discurso de que el
paro juvenil y la precariedad laboral es
estructural y por tanto imposible de
cambiar que ya carecemos de la
suficiente energía como para
transformarlo
y mi pregunta es por qué nos han
convencido tanto de que no existe una
solución
porque nuestro pensamiento está anulado
o porque carece de importancia es más
cuando yo imaginaba el color que tendría
mi futuro era este negro
pero sabe lo que descubrí que según la
física el negro no es realmente un color
sino que simplemente en la ausencia de
luz por eso cuando me comunicaron que
había sido seleccionada para dar esta
charla supe que tenía un objetivo claro
dar luz a todos aquellos que ven su
futuro negro por eso os quiero contar
una historia que a mí me sirvió para
darme cuenta de que cuando realmente
crees que un problema debe cambiar se
puede conseguir
en unas prácticas que hice mis
compañeros y yo empezamos muy
ilusionados porque nos habían prometido
que iban a ser unas prácticas
relacionadas con nuestra formación
nuestra sorpresa fue que cuando el jefe
nos mandó el proyecto que tendríamos que
realizar nos dimos cuenta que éste no
tenía absolutamente nada que ver con el
contenido de las prácticas que nosotros
habíamos aceptado
nos quedamos perplejos y pensamos que
podría ser un error pero no hablando con
jóvenes de años anteriores ellos nos
dijeron que habían vivido la misma
situación que el jefe por no esforzarse
siempre mandaba ese proyecto pensando
que no iba a tener ninguna repercusión
así que junto con mi mejor amiga de las
prácticas decidimos que no debíamos
conformarnos con la situación empezamos
a movilizar a los demás por el grupo de
whatsapp y como podéis imaginar hubo
todo tipo de reacciones hubo que nos
apoyaron firmemente desde el principio
otros que nos hicieron reflexionar sobre
si era conveniente o no quejarse del
asunto otros se negaron a participar en
el problema y otros directamente no
participaron nada pero finalmente a base
de hablar y hablar de dialogar
convencimos aproximadamente un 70% de
que ese proyecto había que cambiarlo
redactamos una queja formal en la que
expresamos nuestro descontento y a
través de argumentos justificados y
razonables expusimos qué era lo que
había que hacer para cambiarlo
nuestro jefe recibió la propuesta y en
un principio parecía molesto
en ese momento algunos compañeros
temieron que hubiera represalias o que
nos pusieron un proyecto aún peor y yo
admito tuve miedo tuve miedo de que
aquel proyecto por el que yo había
causado revuelo al final nos acabará
perjudicando aún más y yo fuera
responsable pero sabéis qué fue lo que
me calmaba que nosotros estábamos
convencidos de que eso era lo que
debíamos hacer que ese proyecto nos
importaba porque queríamos invertir
nuestro tiempo en algo que fuera
realmente útil para nosotros y no
conformarnos porque sabíamos que
conformarnos era lo más fácil pero no lo
más justo y porque por pequeña que
parecía nuestra movilización para
nosotros suponía un cambio realmente
extraordinario así que con este firme
convencimiento y con argumentos
razonables que sostenían todos los
propuestas de cambio nos la admitieron
nos cambiaron un proyecto a uno mejor a
uno que realmente era acorde al
contenido de las prácticas
en consecuencia nosotros estábamos
contentos porque nos habían escuchado y
salimos muy satisfechos de pensar que no
solo los de arriba decidía sino que
también nosotros éramos parte
pues bien este hecho es una simple
anécdota es un hecho aislado pero me di
cuenta que la representación de los
pasos a seguir para conseguir cambiar
cualquier situación este proceso
diseñado por autores como pedro ibarra
analista la sociedad civil y movimientos
sociales lo que busca es dar repercusión
a cada fase y encontrar nuevas formas de
dirigir cambios desde la sociedad esta
escalera por simple que parezca se
utiliza también para analizar la
intervención de los movimientos sociales
en el proceso de políticas públicas esta
escalera sin ir más lejos ejemplifica
los pasos que mis compañeros y yo
seguimos para conseguir el resultado que
considerábamos justo
en muchas ocasiones los jóvenes vivimos
situaciones injustas en el mercado
laboral que damos por hecho que son
imposibles de cambiar pero me pregunta a
todos vosotros es hemos probado intentar
un hecho tan singular como un proyecto
de prácticas me hizo darme cuenta de que
paso por paso persona por persona
problema por problema podríamos los
jóvenes movilizar un gran cambio y en
esta idea de cambio por supuesto habrá
quien esté de acuerdo con vosotros y
quien no habrá a quienes les interese
cambiar las cosas y a quién pero sabéis
que el primer paso es simplemente querer
hacerlo es simplemente querer
transformar porque para subir una
carrera hay que empezar por el primer
escalón verdad y porque ellos aseguró
que en esa subida siempre va a haber
gente que comparta tu problema que
piense como tú y que esté dispuesta
ayudarte por eso con esta historia que
os acabo de contar
quiero que recordéis estas cuatro ideas
la primera actitud los jóvenes
necesitamos la actitud de cambio debemos
seguir impactando constante las
injusticias que vivimos es decir no
debemos normalizar aquello que no es
normal para nosotros la segunda ponernos
metas cortas y alcanzables empezar por
pequeñas cosas elegir cada joven junto a
los de su universidad trabajo o
cualquier otro lugar de formación y
dialogar sobre aquello que queremos
cambiar
tercero creer en el cambio si negocia al
argumentar dialogar pero sobre todo
confiar confiar en que un cambio es
posible
y cuarto y último llevarlo a la práctica
para conseguir un buen resultado porque
muchas pequeñas movilizaciones generan
un cambio extraordinario por eso yo os
animo os animo a que pensemos en
situaciones injustas situaciones que
actualmente nos están haciendo sentir
mal y contarlo y contarlo a vuestros
amigos a vuestras familias a vuestros
compañeros
expresado incluso por redes sociales y
movilizamos a otros para que en cada
causa que consideramos injusta nos ayude
y así conseguiremos negociar con
aquellos que pueden cambiarlo porque si
no lo hacemos
jamás conseguiremos resultados y porque
como se suele decir si todos valemos la
esquina de nuestra casa conseguiremos
que el barrio esté más limpio verdad
martin luther king decía
no me duelen los actos de la gente mala
me duele la indiferencia de la gente
buena
no seamos más indiferentes no seamos
indiferentes ante la precariedad ni
entre nuestra desigualdad laboral por el
simple hecho de ser jóvenes pero tampoco
seamos indiferentes ante cualquier
pequeño problema que todos tenemos que
todos tenemos y todos queremos
en el fondo cambiar para que así al
final el govern de nuestra vida no venga
como un golpe sino como una recompensa
que tanto nos merecemos por todo el
esfuerzo realizado construyamos juntos
con acciones reales un mundo en el que
los jóvenes por fin seamos dueños de
nuestra propia vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]